fala galerinha agora mais um vídeo aqui
na Tailândia rapaziada primeiro dia do
Camp de treino aqui na Tailândia a gente
já fez um Camp que que é Camp né a
galera que não sabe que que é esse
negócio de
train por favor
ah ne Nate ne Nate conversando o
c esse período de Treinamento que você
se prepara para lutar dessa vez a gente
foi convidado pelo my mate Nate para vir
treinar aqui na Tailândia cara na
academia irada e no hotel do cara né
quer dizer da esposa do
cara aqui na Tailândia é assim meu Chap
negócio de de ah o caba que faz ass é a
mulher meu chapa Vem Com a Gente que
agora a gente vai PR academia né
academia PR academia então já já vai
clicando em gostei aí E lembrando que se
der tudo certo Tem vídeo novo todo dia
não vai dar porque nunca dá mas a gente
vai tentar vamos tentar vamos prometer
não tentar a gente tenta então quando o
Winds disser tem vídeo Todo dia pode ser
que vai ter 15 que é bom né No mínimo e
pode ser que tenha 28 se eu me esforçar
muito e tenha
37 caso eu ah ah
entendeu o que que vai acontecer cada
vídeo desse se você vai clicar em Gostei
você pode comentar embaixo você tá na
Tailândia o vai em tal lugar que eu
pesquisei aqui a cheirado talvez a gente
possa ir enfim vamos deixar de de blá
blá blá e venha com a
gente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esse o trem de adaptação tem aqui
as os equipamentos mano
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
bom que que é a
corrida no físico a corrida é aquela
rada a corrida aquela que
o o avião dá um empuxo para decolar
então D uma
queimada e que eu
tô e eu como tenho muita cor para
queimar então entre os exercícios el
botta para correr mas vai Decolar não dá
pr Decolar Ainda não mas qualqu hora eu
decolo ah primeiro dia de camping
aqui na Tailândia na Ásia aqui é de
manhã aí no Brasil já é de noitão ão
fazendo o primeiro treino com Anderson
pra luta dele no Brasil no Rio de
Janeiro vamos com
tudo lá ele
carica cê meu céu aqui pera aí aí que já
já
bot iou até a flor
a
acabou bom gente esse foi o primeiro
Trein de hoje a gente ainda não mostrou
o hotel mas caso você queira é só você
comentar aqui mostra o hotel aí pra
gente a gente vai mostrar o hotel do eu
ia dizer que a gente mostrar
motel n Nate my mate Nate é o hotel dele
e da sunflower né sunflower softel Crab
sunflower é o softel Crab aqui se você
comentar embaixo só comentar assim
mostra o hotel que a gente vai mostrar o
hotel clica no gostei não esquece e em
março a gente
luta sorica
sorica nossa esse videozinho vai ficar
mais mano